a lot of my anxiety symptoms are really
hard to hide sometimes I will shake
someone's hand and be like yeah I have
OCD
[Music]
mental illness was discussed in my home
growing up but it wasn't discussed in
like a positive light it wasn't really
something that I was encouraged to to
seek out I was more so encouraged to
lean on faith I kind of feel like I was
like the prototype in my family because
after I was diagnosed with my mental
illness a few years later my uncle got
diagnosed and then to my cousin's dead
and when I first was experiencing the
symptoms everyone thought that I was
just being a rebellious teenager the
consideration that I might be going
through something deeper than that was
never even considered I think just being
a first-generation mexican-american my
parents thought that my symptoms or my
expression was a choice and a lot of
times it was very like you got to stop
talking in school you have anger
problems or so it was not necessarily
seen as something that I can work
towards but it was seen as a defective
trait yeah for me it wasn't it's who I
was so last year in Oscars hospitalized
that the conversations and mental help
was brought up in my family and I don't
think it was done on purpose I think it
was just never had a space to do it and
currently like accustomed to it I relate
to that it just never really came up
right yeah I have a memory of my sister
saying like I think that sparkle has OCD
from a really young age it wasn't really
discussed outside of that and I never
really got help until it got so bad that
I would have died if I didn't
[Music]
probably not like in high school and
stuff like I was always like the even
just cool dude like everybody seemed
like I had together really so I think it
would probably be surprising people that
I'm dealing with bipolar disorder
because it just seemed like everything
was so in order I think everything was
looking how I was supposed to look so I
guess for some people it would be like
surprise for me I'm surprised like I
just try to carry on myself the exact
opposite of what people would think so I
can make an effort to hide it a lot
better you think of depression and you
think of just some gloomy person in the
corner and I tried my best not to be
that person to not let anybody know
because I was extremely insecure about
it I didn't want anybody to know that I
was struggling with something that I
couldn't really put into words I'm so
open about it they're like any stranger
on the street
like if it should happen to come up I
will shake someone's hand and be like
yeah I have OCD because I actually feel
like hiding it like I'd rather tell
somebody oh yeah by the way I'm bipolar
so if I ever like start acting a little
bit different like that might be why
[Music]
I was first diagnosed with schizophrenia
and that was after seeing a psychiatrist
for five minutes she sat with me looked
at me she's like okay you have
schizophrenia just because I told her I
had hallucinations but I was later
diagnosed as bipolar one so I think it's
really important that these medical
professionals really take the time to
listen to their patient and to figure
out what's really going on and not just
you know be so jaded by all their other
past patients that they're not listening
to the person you know sitting right in
front of them
I do trust medical professionals like I
believe for the most part that they're
trying to do what's best for you and we
can't allow like mistakes or things that
happen in every career every field
discourage us or others from going and
getting help from these people but what
if it was a person that had a more
severe disability like somebody who
can't go a day who if they dropped the
ball that could land them in the
hospital I have seen some situations
where there was a mix-up you know and
one person got someone else's medication
and you can't take that back
before I was diagnosed with Bipolar I
thought I was absolutely everything
because I was bipolar and I'd be going
through all these different manic
episodes and you know one week I'd be
self diagnosing myself as this and the
next week I'm not I see people struggle
mostly with diagnosis acceptance so I
think self diagnosis can really just
turn into denial it's interesting the
first time that I went into a therapist
and said I think I have an eating
disorder I told her the amount of times
a day that I was purging and it was all
day every day and she said you're not
thin enough it's not a problem unless
you get thinner and thinner so it took
me two more years to go and get help a
second time I did end up getting
diagnosed later on with both bulimia and
anorexia at different points in time but
I think it was good during those two
years that I didn't have a diagnosis to
still be able to talk to people like to
still be able to talk to my friends and
say like I have an eating disorder
I'm not diagnosed but I have an eating
disorder before I got Dennis about
bipolar disorder I noticed that he might
my freshman year at college that I
thought I was depressed and I'm reaching
out and telling someone my girlfriend to
Sam and she was like no you're not
depressed and so I sometimes when you're
like self diagnosed you kind of don't
get Chi the same as being banished by a
doctor but I think people know to
themselves know themselves well so I
think it should be taken more seriously
when people at least attempt that self
diagnosing himself
when I did feel at my lowest points the
combinations of therapy and medications
definitely seemed to help but it's been
a couple years now since that and even
when I don't feel necessarily okay or if
I feel like I'm struggling I don't feel
the need to run to therapy or from
medications at this point I feel like
I've grown and learned a lot from what I
went through and learned my own coping
mechanisms to say that I don't
necessarily need to fall on that so it's
not something that as of now I can say
that it works for me because I don't
necessarily need it as of now I'm torn
with the whole therapy thing medication
I'm all for I've been on medication
since I was 16 and it's actually really
helped me get through my different moods
and keeping me stable but as for therapy
sometimes I feel like when I go I'm just
like retrigger
you know the trauma inside me so I don't
really like to talk about it but I agree
with you guys it doesn't work for a lot
of people not so much for me but it I I
would recommend therapy definitely well
in for me going to therapy say
definitely saved my life getting the
diagnosis gave me something tangible to
hold on to when my like whole world was
slipping away from me and I had no idea
what to do as far as the conversation
around medication goes like a lot of
people don't realize that no matter what
medication is never like a perfect
answer like it's always only like 40 50
percent effective you still need peer
support you still need to like accept
what's going on and work on it on a
personal level like no matter what yeah
I think that for me it's what like
allows me to do that work and in terms
of anxiety medication like my anxiety
medication like lets me leave the house
to go get there and like let it slows my
brain down enough that I'm able to like
think about it and then do the work yeah
maybe a lot of them
I would say that I would completely take
back you know go back in time and and
not go through the darker parts of my
life but it's helped me grow a lot as a
person I wouldn't change the person that
I've become how stronger I've been from
it how much more confidence I've had in
myself had I not gone through that I
wouldn't take that back
it truly is so hard because in one way
like it has made me who I am today it
has made me so much more empathetic it
literally I'm a mental health writer and
it started my career I wouldn't have the
career that I have I wouldn't have the
connections that I have but then
thinking of how like I have osteoporosis
I have bone problems I have teeth
problems because of my eating disorder
in so it's like I wouldn't take away my
past but if I could snap my fingers and
not have to deal with it for the rest of
my life that would be excellent
very much so thankful that I went
through the things that I went through
because I've seen how it's affected my
close friends my family it gives me the
responsibility to be a voice for the
voiceless especially people in my
community who go through these things
who don't know what's going on have no
experience but with it at all and for
someone like me to just put step out on
a limb and just talk about it I think I
was chose to have that role my parents
were like convinced that I was just
defective and so now that I'm convincing
my parents that I wasn't just making
this up they're able to see that I'm
working towards something but they still
have to deal with me they still have to
ask me how are you doing they still have
to see me at the hospital and being in
your 20s is not easy to question if your
life is you know a worth it because
you aren't just making a lasting effect
on yourself it really affects everybody
and I think that if I didn't have my
disorder I wouldn't be Who I am and I'm
okay with that because life is more than
just me I do believe that we should be
positive about our mental illnesses so
we can bring other people up who aren't
even ready to accept that they're going
through something right now if they see
us feeling like so negative and like we
wish we could just rip all this way
which I totally understand like how
everybody feels I'm not trying to say
that it's so much easier anything all
I'm trying to say is is that it's part
of your life not your entire life like
my life is so much more my beautiful
husband like my wonderful family my cute
chihuahuas like that's my life like my
life isn't that I'm bipolar that I have
an eating disorder or that I experience
sexual trauma this is such a hard one
for all of us I don't want to be in this
line I want to be in the middle because
having this illness like with you it it
makes me who I am today you know it's
made me stronger it's made me appreciate
what I have it's made me appreciate
being happy because if you're living
with a mental illness some of us wake up
every day just wishing to god that they
could put a smile on their face and it
actually means something it's so hard
you know and I think life would be
easier without taking all those pills
without not knowing if I could even have
a child because I can't bear a baby with
taking all these pills it's it sucks at
the same time there's so many people out
there who live with these illnesses and
I think it's up to us to help them and
to you know be bear strengths and to
educate people because who else is going
to do it if not us guys if you're
struggling with an addiction if you're
struggling with a mental illness please
ask for support you know there are
people here for you
giving their time freely to be of
support we so appreciate you guys taking
the time to watch this and empathize
with the cast members as always follow
us on Instagram leave a comment below
and we'll see you next time
[Music]